i
[Música]
ah
el premio con kurt es el premio
literario más prestigioso de francia fue
creado en 1903 sin embargo este 2020 a
causa de la pandemia no ha podido ser
anunciado desde el restaurante tuvo en
el barrio de la ópera como lo suele ser
desde hace más de 100 años tampoco pudo
ser desvelado desde allí el premio
renaudeau una suerte de hermano menor
alternativo del conjuro creado 23 años
después a raíz de la pandemia y debido
al cierre de los restaurantes tampoco se
pudo reunir cada primer martes de mes la
academia del goncourt para ir eligiendo
los mejores libros del año en curso
finalmente la ceremonia algún curso se
realizó por videoconferencia llegaron
cuatro finalistas de un total de 500
libros el vástago rebelde del reino do
en cambio eligió la sede de la revista
literaria libre para realizar su
ceremonia el concurso y su particular
premio un cheque de diez euros fue para
las de letelier y su libro anomalías el
de nodo en cambio para nadie el en la
font y su libro historia del hijo
[Música]
la feria internacional del libro de
guadalajara se lleva a cabo de manera
virtual por lo que tuvo que recortar su
programa de actividades a sólo 300 en
vez de las 3000 que solía tener marisol
schulz la directora del encuentro
reconoció que no había ni presupuesto ni
logística ni plataforma para llevar a
cabo la cantidad de eventos acostumbrada
a sí mismo la ffyl se da en el marco de
las críticas del presidente lópez
obrador en el sentido de que la feria
últimamente se ha politizado se ha usado
para cuestionar a su gobierno y promover
dijo el conservadurismo este encuentro
librero uno de los más grandes del mundo
comenzó con la entrega del premio fil de
literatura en lenguas romances a la
portuguesa lidia jorge asimismo se
entregó de manera virtual la medalla
carlos fuentes al escritor cubano
leonardo padura ha habido y habrá
encuentros de corte político también
como la mesa redonda para analizar la
relación que tendrá méxico con el nuevo
gobierno de eeuu el plato fuerte será
sin duda la presencia del nobel salman
rushdie en este encuentro que tendrá
todavía varias sorpresas de aquí al 6 de
diciembre
[Música]
editoriales y librerías completan esta
alteración pandémica al sector literario
sin ferias físicas y con librerías
cerradas las casas de edición han tenido
que dosificar sus novedades para no
sentenciar a los autores mientras que de
manera global las librerías se están
alternando envíos a domicilio con
protocolos para no morir ha sido existen
mejor que otros sectores pero el 2020
les dejará en españa sin el 20 por
ciento de ventas anuales a colombia sin
el 30 por ciento y argentinas sin más
del 40 por ciento hay librerías que no
pueden sostener un modelo digital y por
eso la alcaldía de parís entre muchas
otras ha pedido a comprar en el comercio
de barrio y no hay un amazon una
petición que se une a otra fundamental y
es declarar las librerías un servicio
esencial méxico y bélgica lo han hecho
en pandemia pero el grito general es
asimilar que son lugares seguros y que
los libros no son sólo refugios sino
también salvavidas para libreros
editoriales y lectores
[Música]